[Music]
so
so
so
so
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast
live stream number 42 part
b and part b is taking place on a brand
new stream for some reason
that we do not know youtube suddenly
without warning ended
our prior stream and forced us to create
a new one so there are no guarantees
here
we can say however that your super chats
from the prior stream were captured so
don't worry nothing was lost there if
you submitted a question we have it
and we will get going here and get to as
many as we can
all right all right let's do it uh we're
going to begin
uh with a few from last time
uh and two are
the first is just a comment i hope my
sanity does not come at the cost of
yours
whether unity 2020 happens or not these
podcasts are doing a service for people
who think the world around them has gone
crazy
thank you appreciate that yes indeed
next question from episode 41 do you
think that abiogenesis may be an ongoing
process
and that new life forms may appear near
deep ocean vents for example without us
noticing
well if they did come into existence at
deep ocean vents i would not notice
because
i just don't get there very frequently
um
well here's the thing so uh give me a
little leash here this is um
worth understanding the fact is there
are
a great many different dna codes you
could have
so you can imagine a great many
different mappings
of three letter codons to the particular
amino acids that they encode
so even if you had the accidental
creation of a novel tree of life that
used dna
right even if you just happened to land
on the dna formulation you would still
expect a different mapping
between the amino acids in the proteins
and the dna
code the fact that everything on earth
that uses dna so prions would be
excluded from this
well primes are excluded in the sense
that they reproduce
patterns without going through a dna
phase but
nevermind primes for a second that all
the plants animals fungi and other
living creatures that we see
use the same dna code tells us
that they emerge from the same tree of
life if we found
a version of life that used either a
different
molecule to transmit information or
contained a different encoding
then we would have reason to suspect a
new tree of life so
this is all to say we don't have
multiple trees darwin didn't know that
we didn't have multiple trees in fact in
the origin of species he leaves open the
possibility that there are more than one
tree
we now know better because we have the
molecular techniques to identify
that at least all living creatures seem
to derive from one
ancestor but if it did happen a they
would probably
blink out of existence very quickly we
don't know if that has happened but
we don't see evidence of it and
if they didn't blink out of existence
and they began to
evolve we would be able to detect that
they were discontinuous from the tree of
life
um because it would be very striking
that they did not use the same encodings
so i'm just i'm going to take issue with
one thing and what you said which is i
can't
imagine why we would expect that a new
form of life would have happened upon
dna
this is i mean this strikes me as the
least probable part of it
and you know once you've happened upon
dna independently like
staggeringly stagnantly unlikely um sure
it might use
different uh different codes from there
on but you know this
this is a this is a theme of course that
you know that i explored in the science
fiction that i was writing
a couple years ago that has been sort of
back burned for the moment but the idea
of
um other evolutions of life in even
within our galaxy seems actually very
very likely
um but we will know that it is a
different origin by the fact that it has
a different what i came to start calling
an infomall an information molecule
and you know why why would we start with
the premise that you know even if it had
the same dna it would have a different
code like just
just begin with if it's really a new
origin of life it's almost certain to
use
um to have some different molecule whose
business is transmitting information
well i'm going to take issue with your
taking issue with my statement because
all i was saying is
even in the unlikely event that dna was
the core molecule which would
hide the fact of it being a separate
evolution we would still readily detect
it so i'm not saying it's likely at all
i'm just saying
even in the event that we are dealt the
unlucky
um confusing fact of a dna based life
form that isn't
from the same tree we would still be
able to see it easily yeah
for for those watching uh i will just
point out that i have managed to con
uh two our two younger cats fairfax and
moxie now on the scene
into standing behind us and showing
their their cute little selves
so that's them post cream meal
okay snakes have always been strongly
present in human culture whether as a
force of good or evil
do snakes and humans have an
evolutionary history or link
so they there is no phylogenetic
uh common ancestor between snakes that
isn't the same common ancestor
uh that all mammals have with all
reptiles that is to say we do of course
have the most recent coming associated
with snakes as we do with every single
life form on the planet and you know in
keeping with that last question
there was only one evolution of life on
the planet that stuck we know that
because we have this one information
molecule that is
in which life is coated the same way um
with you know the
exceptions being viruses um there seems
to be multiple evolutions
of um of viral code
you have said yeah i don't that's not
what i mean to imply i believe that all
viruses that we know of derived from
that tree of life
most likely way is that they are
effectively
genomic escapees from some creature but
they are not
evolved independently okay that's what i
thought you had said
way back when we were first doing this
which took me very surprising okay so we
have we have just the one
the one tree um and so you know we're no
more closely related to
snakes um than a kangaroo is for
instance
um but the fact that many snakes
although by no means all um are actually
capable of posing a remarkable threat to
humans means that any rule that suggests
that you should be wary of snakes
is likely to be a powerful one and to
persist in cultures
so we could say a lot more about this
maybe you want to add just a well i just
want to
add that that snakes are very
widespread there in fact the most
specious
clade of legless lizards that exists
yeah and the most dangerous all of the
other times that lizards have evolved
leglessness and it has happened several
times
those legless lizards mostly keep to
themselves and when i say they mostly
keep to themselves they actually do that
they do not suddenly emerge well armed
and
men shoot people true yeah
yes i'm hoping that a certain number of
people are sitting at home
wondering if they really heard us just
claim that snakes were lizards which we
did
yeah and that uh lizards lost their legs
more than once
and only snakes really well they kind of
ran with it
that's an odd way to put that yes if
you're curious about how snakes could
possibly
be lizards and what that means i wrote
an essay years ago which you can find
under the heading um on being a fish
and so in some of your fish free time
you can read that essay and discover
um about seals being bears and the like
seals being bears and
one more thing about snakes and really
you know don't don't get me started i
could spend
many hours talking about snakes um and i
have
in the past to get paid for it i used to
get paid to talk about snakes among
other things
um bowids which is a uh a group of
snakes that includes of course the boas
and is a fairly basal group that is to
say um
it that family hasn't changed as much
since
all of the rest of the snakes have
changed a lot as as the other ones have
um actually in their early development
have
um a little pelvis and little tiny hind
limbs
and those things mostly or entirely
disappear
as uh when they're adults but you
actually see that happening
uh developing and then disappearing yes
yes yes yes they never you never see
posts with little tiny legs right
on the outside but if you can see that
if you dissect them
you can see a little pelvis and yeah and
femurs i think they don't have the
um the tibia and um
um fibula yeah yeah boweds which are
very popular in the pet trade
they're staggeringly popular if i had a
boat we'd we don't keep snakes but if i
had a boat i would name it
david poet you would i would yeah yes
and i would appreciate that okay yeah
okay
are ancient fairy tales and myths about
monsters really warnings to kids about
serial killers and child molesters
um well they are
certainly well ancient ones are
certainly warnings about
something and how they work we don't
know we could speculate and certainly
some of these things
might be warnings about particular
dangerous details of the world i think
eric
i think it's this point originally um
makes a point about
evil step parent
mythology which actually turns out to be
a warning about
evil step parents you don't say
right i do how did he get there that
seems like quite a leap well i mean i
think the point is
evolutionarily there's a very good
reason for this pattern right
somebody if step parents being more
likely to
cause harm to children than than genetic
parents
right and you could imagine a woman
steps into a man's life he's got
kids she has no genetic interest in
those kids
so um in order to curry favor with the
man
she would have to play nice with those
kids but of course when he wasn't around
a different side of her might emerge
sure so the wicked stepmother is
a resonant trope because there will have
been many wicked stepmothers in history
which is not to say
that step parents are inherently bad in
fact human beings
routinely adopt other they adopt
children that are not related to them
now historically speaking
adoption would have existed and it would
in general have been
babies or children who were related
but the ability to adopt uh
offspring that are not yours and treat
them very well exists but the chances of
a parent being a bad parent go
up if the child is not related i mean i
would point out that even our
keeping of pets is effectively our
ability to feel love for
and to take care of a creature that is
really not closely related to us at all
so that capacity exists but it fails
more often when children
are not related and the step parent
situation given the long lives of human
beings
and the likelihood that one partner dies
or something
the chances that a child will encounter
a wicked step parent is fairly high
and stories that warn of that phenomenon
uh you know give them a little bit of uh
um
i wouldn't say an advantage but reduce
the disadvantage of the situation and
find themselves in
yeah i guess i would just add uh with
regard to ancient fairy tales and myths
being monster
about monsters really warning kids about
serial killers and child molesters
of course there are also going to be
distinct
non-human monstrous threats in each of
the cultures
in which such fairy tales exist and so
you would expect the monsters
to resemble something that is actually a
possibility in the individual
environments uh where
the particular fairy tales emerge from
which brings us to komodo dragons
yes it does what do you want to say
about coming to dragons nothing i just
you just want to talk about if you were
talking you're just you're you're
playing my role okay yeah you're exactly
bringing up lizards
all the time well somebody's got
research
okay the next question before we get
into questions uh from the last hour
episode 42 is from the discord channel
um i told i said that we would answer a
question from discord once a week
that they had voted on that they wanted
answered and here it is what do you
perceive
to be the downstream consequences of the
destigmatization of sex work
particularly in young women so this
this warrants this warrants so much and
i will begin
um by saying uh that
this not exactly about sex work but that
i've got an essay that's
that should be published within a few
days at this point it's not yet out on
the evolution of sex and the evolution
of love and
on um what i'm calling a kind of sexual
autism
which can be produced by um by
basically being an avid watcher of
pornography
so pornography and sex work are
not exactly not entirely overlapping
but this movement that calls itself sex
positive
which basically says you know any sex at
any time
is inherently good and sex work is
inherently good and we need to
remove all stigma associated with it
has clearly been named
in the same vein as many of these modern
movements
such that if you resist it it makes you
seem like a prude what are you not sex
positive are you sex negative do you not
like sex
well no so i would say and this is an
argument that we have we have both made
um that the so-called sex positive
movement is actually
an anti-love anti-connection and
really in a lot of ways an anti-sex
movement because it it does
move women um especially you know young
women
into a mode uh that is more like the
one of one of the less honorable typical
male modes
rather than uh sort of being interested
in a society
and moving um men and women both
into a mode that is more like the
ancestral female mode with regard to
interest in long-term bond and
commitment and and
healthy and wonderful and surprising
sexuality
yeah i would just say uh in addition
that the sex drive
is among the most powerful motivators in
the human
arsenal and that the rendering
of many readily accessible ways
to scratch that itch is
having totally arbitrary effects on
society it affects the way
families form it affects whether people
are
getting the right kind of emotional
stimulation to feel
healthy it affects whether people are
accomplishing important things that
require
you know striving and risk-taking and
all of these things and basically
you know because sex is fun
people want easy access to it but easy
access to it
is interfacing with what human beings
are
in a very negative way and it is uh i
would think
is spectacularly disempowering of women
that women effectively end up
competing with uh things that provide
satisfaction that don't involve any
commitment at all like
prostitution and like porn and
things like this and so basically it um
it is rendering the meaning in life
much less meaningful and so you know
that's a hard thing to say because as
you say
you're immediately understood to be a
prude if you
um if you oppose this and i would just
say
the the proper way to think about this
involves thinking about tantric sex
which is obviously
not prudish or uh sex
negative if that's even a thing it's
obviously extremely sex positive but
what it is about is about
managing sexual desire in a way that
heightens sexual pleasure rather than
oh if sexual pleasure is good then more
and easier and you know less
less meaningful so um you know
sex positivity needs to be reinvented as
something that is
actually sex positive rather than just
something that is in favor of more
quantity of whatever low-grade sexual
satisfaction
is on offer that's right and you use the
word if if we had
a one word answer to this question you
used it in that so the question again
just to wrap up
what do you perceive to be the
downstream consequences of the
de-stigmatization of sex work
particularly in young women
disempowerment disempowerment of of
women
and and therefore really ultimately of
of everyone
okay next question thoughts on longevity
and or immortality
is death useful in the sense that it may
push a sense of urgency
if given the option would you live
forever
god no that's a lot of questions yeah um
so this is a tough one and nobody ever
likes my answer on this which is a
evolution solved this problem long long
ago and the fact that you don't like the
answer doesn't mean it isn't the best
answer going
right what evolution has done is it has
solved all of the problems that block us
from
immortality or indefinite longevity
which is probably the better way to say
it
it has solved them by allowing you to
take the part of you
that matters and to upload it to the
next generation
minus the part that's no longer relevant
and so the point is
we do this and we do it through the
production of offspring and those
offspring
take a tremendous amount from us at a
cognitive and emotional level that's
a large part of the meaning of childhood
is the conveying of
important concepts skills everything
else to
creatures that matter because preserving
your body indefinitely
a it ain't gonna happen and b it
wouldn't be a good solution because for
one thing
what is it that you think you know
that's so all fired important that we
need to keep your version of it around
forever
right you want to keep seeing things we
get that right we are all
wired to want to continue to live and so
the idea that death is frightening and
makes you
look for alternatives to it is natural
but but the fact is first of all if
you've fixed the body so it could live
forever
you won't have fixed the brain which
creates an obvious computing problem
right even if you get past the cellular
level problems the brain
is built to remember a certain number of
things and forget most
things and it's built to do so over a
span of
80 maybe 100 years we don't have a
mechanism for figuring out how to forget
enough stuff that you could live 500
years
without creating a problem right so
brains are going to fail
even if we cured the body the brain
would fail for its own
informational reasons if you could cure
the brain what would life look like when
you were young you'd be forgetting so
much stuff in order to leave
room to remember that rare thing that
actually was going to matter in a life
of 500 or 1000 years
that you'd be unrecognizable as a person
and i think the fact that anybody thinks
that this is workable
is a measure of their wishful thinking
more than it is a measure of the
tractability of the problem it's not
tractable
and what do you know we already have a
solution and
embrace it because it is the fact that
your death is coming that gives
life meaning and makes it precious so
you know treat it as precious
and at the moment you think we really
have to solve this problem
look at how most people live right is
there something
eternal about what they're doing are
they spending their time in a way that
makes you think oh
actually every moment of human life is
precious and we should you know
no people squander life so um
i don't know i think we just all need to
grow up and get over this fantasy and
realize life is precious and it ends
and um the the way to make that less
tragic
is to pass on things that matter to
children
wonderful have you two
so the answer to the first part of this
question is i have not so i'm
i'm gonna punt this to you brett have
you two heard of taurus tech in
california
their arc crystal a lab-grown solid
state machine and its purported effects
are intriguing but direly needs study
replication
they state that the tech has a resonant
field effect to improve cell growth
longevity and robustness if true could
this have any impact on the immortality
versus senescence telomere issue
um i would need to look at that i must
say the description there
strikes me is not very likely yeah
because i haven't heard of it i can't i
don't want to dismiss it because
i don't know but yeah i'm skeptical
how does the significantly reduced
amount of adhd and asperger's in amish
communities compare with the
over-medication epidemic
and the outmoded hidden curriculum in
schools is it as simple as letting
children be free range
so there's a lot in here i'm not sure
what quote-unquote hidden curriculum
refers to here i
suspect i have my suspicions about what
it might mean
but i don't actually know that that
phrase in quotes
caps so i'm not sure um but the
the larger question is fascinating you
know is
i didn't know so this is a the claim in
the question
is that amish communities experience
lower rates of adhd and asperger's
than do um sort of general population in
the us at large
if that's true and that sounds likely to
be true to me but i don't know it to be
true
um to what might we ascribe this
and so the two so putting aside the
hidden curriculum question here
uh the two possible explanations that
this questioner
suggests is pharmaceuticals the
over-medication epidemic
and um basically over-scheduling i guess
i would say with regarding
uh letting children be free-range and i
would
you know i think i think that 100 both
of these things
have to do with failures and development
that mainstream american children are
experiencing
at terrifying rates that they aren't
being allowed to
take risks and live and explore and
actually make mistakes for themselves
either actually i wish to say let them
be free range
don't make them have lessons you know
every single moment
of every single day and this is of
course speaking
absent the coveted lockdowns and virtual
schools and such which changes
everything but then also do not drug
them into submission
you know some some people need some
mood disrupting or enhancing drugs in
order to live
full and normal lives we should always
always
think very very carefully before we give
any drugs to children
and we should also think very very
carefully about what that's going to do
for development when it's something as
powerful as for instance
speed or an ssri
i would add that what we can say
almost for sure is that adhd
to the extent it exists and aspergers
are
sure to be at least in part responses to
novel phenomena and those novel
phenomena can be
pharmaceutical in nature but they can
also be
something like screens and in fact there
was a very interesting
study 10 years ago or so
that actually advanced to the hypothesis
that autism was being caused by
screen time on the basis that it seemed
to
correlate with bad weather the
implication being children were indoors
more
and exposed to televisions the idea
underlying the whole thing
was that by
you're placed in front of a screen in a
way that uh no ancestor
would have been you see a person there
they might be a face distance apart and
they are emoting and talking but they
don't respond to you and so
in some people this would break the
developmental process that would cause
interaction between two people who were
face to face
from developing properly so is that
right
i don't know but it's plausible and then
this will change now that screens are
more
interactive right television was a very
passive
environment for somebody to sit in front
of now these screens involve
some kind of exchange of information you
may be typing
you know um but anyway these things will
change over time but the underlying
aspect is the novelty of the environment
you are built to develop
properly in an environment that looks
like your ancestors environment
and the farther your environment looks
from that or worse the faster it's
changing
the more likely you are to disrupt
development and
create uh you know dental problems
eye problems emotional problems
expect a culture like the amish or like
mennonites
who reject many of the hyper-novel
aspects of our modern culture
to of course show fewer
hyper-modern diseases and pathologies as
well yeah of course
totally yeah
polygenic and multifaceted though it may
be
could you please elaborate on why
cognitive capacity should not be
disparate across subpopulations due to
genetic factors
i'm generally curious please disregard
if necessary
related to my last comment satoshi
kanasawa has
written a fairly persuasive argument
vis-a-vis differential selective
pressure between different environments
on cognition
again please disregard if this is risky
so i don't know kind of saw why do you
know
no um we're going to get tangled over
this again and again and again and
probably it
requires a longer explanation somewhere
but the question isn't are there going
to be
differences in cognition based on
differences in local environments
there will be will those be manifest
in genetic that is to say heritable in
the narrow scientific sense of that term
will they be manifest there or will they
be transmitted in a different
way which is to say if you
grow up in the arctic your cognition
will be adjusted to the arctic but it
will be transmitted to you in large
measure culturally
right so the question is do we expect a
residual
in the genetically programmed and
hardwired
layer or do we expect the differences to
be passed on
uh culturally and through learning and
my
in which case they're entirely
democratizable they're democratizable
exactly and so the question is
could there be differences in
the hardwired capacity of brains yes
there can be differences between
populations in fact here's the bitter
pill
there have to have been those
differences that's how we got big brains
is
different populations had different
levels of uh capacity based on how much
brain they had and those with more
capacity outcompeted those with less
so there's that except neanderthals
right well we don't exactly know what
went on with neanderthals but
for another day but the point is yes
those differences can exist
yes they must have existed but in the
modern human population
where we are all one species is it
likely that populations have inherited
substantially different
capacity differences no i don't believe
so will they have inherited
some yeah it's be very unusual if the
answer was
exactly zero but the a i wouldn't know
which populations to bet on
and b the question is are the
differences between populations in terms
of their capacity relative to our shared
environment
are those differences likely to be large
relative to the part that is transmitted
culturally
or small and my bet is almost
unmeasurable
that would be my bet
um please make unity long-term
i need a we need a manifesto of
bipartisan issues term limits
election tax and education reform
legalize pot find and run 535 courageous
patriots for every seat in congress and
start real
long-term change all right first we need
to get our twitter account back
now i appreciate it obviously to the
extent that
unity is a resonant idea it is a timely
idea
it needs to uh extend well beyond the
presidential election of 2020. no
question
we do have a national emergency though
and so for the moment we're focused on
the highest leverage pressure point that
we've got
in hopes of getting us pointed in the
right direction as quickly as possible
yeah and we might also actually come
back to
this question of whether or not we think
bipartisan just says that there are
people
on on left and right that really want
this these things term limits election
tax education reform et cetera
but the legalization of pot is actually
itself strangely polarizing
i have i've begun to see a number of
people basically
making making the argument that because
it is
uh not fully understood in terms
of its mental effects
um that it should not be legalized and
it sounds very much like prohibition to
me and i you know it's not it's not
where i fall
um but i am just recently becoming aware
of
sort of which i i didn't ever predict
you know we
for years were just um like never
thought we'd live to see the day
uh when it would be um common and legal
and fine
and frankly it seems like such a smaller
deal than alcohol
in so many regards um but there are
there are those who oppose it that's
that's
that's interesting to me i don't i don't
know much about that movement
but on on the basis that uh we don't
know
its effects i must say i'm far
more worried about television and
facebook than i am yeah
of the far i mean if even if we just
stick to you know exogenous chemicals
that we're
encouraging people or allowing people to
take into their bodies
let's go after pharmaceuticals rather
than
something a substance with which humans
have
um tens probably hundreds of thousands
of years of history
and some ability you know i know maybe
hundreds of thousands is
considerably more than but i would say
at least 10.
don't know it's going to be thousands of
years of history for sure but the thing
is you can also
uh modulate it you can yeah you
the effects are ones that you are aware
of in large measure and you can decide
whether they are positive or negative
where whereas the uh
fact of television and facebook makes
you
think like a corporation right that's a
hazard right there and you can't even
detect you're doing it
right and so um i would just say
uh you know will there be negative
effects of
people uh using marijuana
yes but we have so many of these
cognitively disruptive
forces that cause you to do self-harm
that something that has arbitrary
effects is not the place to spend your
time
worrying and actually i think that i
think actually if i were to point to a
big risk of marijuana
it's that market forces drove farmers to
create selective forces on the marijuana
itself to increase the thc
content so high and simultaneously
decrease the cbd
content such that you have uh much more
basically much more ability to let um a
small amount get you high
but the thc tends to come with sort of
psychotic effects
and the cbd would tend to as far as i
understand it along with some other
active molecules we don't even have
named yet for the most part
um mitigating effects of the wait don't
step on the trackpad kitkat
um some of the other bioactive molecules
in marijuana seem to in its
less human selected state mitigate the
psychosis
effects of the thc and now we have such
strong weed
that it's actually much more dangerous
than it was back when
uh you know back when it was becoming
something that was
you know increasingly widespread um
among young people
well interestingly it's not really even
market forces i would say that did that
it was the way we
punish right because yeah it was it was
criminal
it was the law it was the law you
punished on the basis of the weight
and so but i mean it was also about
crossing borders right it was i think
the same thing um so the point is well
maybe
detection exactly but the you were
avoiding the law
you made it stronger so that less weed
did
had greater effect which meant that when
you were caught with it the weight that
was recorded was lower and the chances
of it being found crossing a border is
lower so that's the law causing it to be
concentrated which has now turned it
into actually quite a powerful drug
where it was
not a powerful drug so back when it
began to be demonized
it was pretty mild yeah and pretty
manageable and so to the extent
that far safer to sit around with a
bunch of friends smoking a spliff in the
50s then
sharing you know then each of you having
a six-pack right
yeah i mean you're less likely to get
into a fight less likely to crash your
car
all sorts of things so the
fact that a safe drug was rendered
dangerous by our treating it as if it
was dangerous
and now it's something that we have to
worry about because actually the effects
are substantial that's an argument
against uh trying to regulate it rather
than
uh regulating it into oblivion which
doesn't work and makes it worse
yeah okay i don't know what this one
means
do you know should i read it uh
um i have no idea what that means so
it's a reference to to
gator uh on the
character on twitter whom we know
well al quinn if you want to clarify uh
we will read it but not knowing what
this is about i'm not going to
read this out loud okay what are your
thoughts on the social moral and ethical
implications of technology
such as crispr gene editing becoming
available and accessible to the masses
well as i've said before i don't believe
we have the rosetta stone we have the
typewriter but we don't have the rosetta
stone in crispr
we will eventually have the rosetta
stone at which point it becomes a very
dangerous
phenomenon and as the price point drops
and it becomes accessible to more people
uh
we're in danger but the number of things
where this is the case
um you know the relatively low price
point to
composite viruses and imbue them with
dangerous characteristics is apparently
uh already a level where
you know something well below a state
level actor could deliver a huge blow
so dangerous we have to rethink how
we do all of these things the ability
for some
entity to do something that is in its
interest where
either the risk of it spilling out into
the world and doing
spectacular levels of externalized harm
is there
or it could intentionally be weaponized
you know we're going to run into this
technology after technology and at some
level
you know just as we decide with the
right to bear arms that the right to
bear arms does not involve
your right to a bazooka or to a nuclear
weapon
right we have to decide what we're going
to do about the technologies that we
cannot afford
to be available to every uh insane
person or criminal organization
you know and it's not an easy question
it's it's going to involve
a new understanding of the legal limits
of
certain rights on the other hand all of
our well-being is depending on the
ability to figure out how to regulate
those things
yes was there resistance to the initial
1970s real-life enactment of the turner
ward play that started evergreen's day
of absence ritual
uh yearly theatrical performance might
have sufficed as a learning device
um i don't think so so this is this is
in reference to
the the day of absence and day of
presence ritual that began
i don't know when maybe in the 90s
something maybe it began it
began almost at the beginning oh did it
okay so the original play is
50s i think 60s 50 60s
um and then this day of absence um
which was established to demonstrate the
importance of black people in in the
original
play the town and on campus on campus
um then got reversed in 2017 to much
fanfare
um was there any resistance i you know
i've never heard of any resistance no i
i don't think there was um and you know
what a yearly theatrical performance
have sufficed
i don't know uh you know i suspect that
it might like if it was really just
that play year after year after year it
might have become
it might just have become too
commonplace just you know just the way
you don't
you don't notice your furniture until
something happens on it or you move it
around or something like
you need to actually move stuff no
matter how powerful and necessary it is
in your life
you need to change it up in order to be
reminded of its
power and utility so you know you know
even just a rotating cycle of you know
that and our town and you know
just a number of other plays but
possibly
that were that were put on as part of
this kind of analysis
might have been um might have been
powerful and
no i don't think that that was ever part
of the part of the scene
yep i agree and something to change it
up would probably be necessary but i i
agree i mean the whole purpose of a play
is to teach
something or to reveal something by
performing it rather than
um yeah dragging it into the world yeah
so um next one my vote is that you draft
your cat for unity 2020.
um because presumably he's willing to
share his ass with the world
and that would make him a good candidate
i don't i think he's not quite
up to the job actually
next one to what degree if any is unity
inspired by the roman office of console
is this an office that you would like to
see integrated or resurrected into our
system
i don't know my roman history well
enough to to speak to this
yeah uh you've caught me off guard um
it's certainly not
consciously deriving from it but i'll
need to look into it more to
to know whether there's something to
revive there i i have heard it mentioned
in a couple of places though
okay uh what time are we at zach
38 okay we'll do uh three more here and
then we'll skip to the next uh
next stream is there a tie-in with what
is going on now
and the dove and hawk uh
gtm game theory manifestation i don't
know what gtm stands for here
where the dove mindset grew too large
and self-imposed segregation and now the
pendulum has swung to the opposite side
with progressives
um i'm trying to map it on to that
yeah i don't i don't see it i mean i
think what really happened is you have
a you have two parties that have taken
up
influence peddling their influence
peddling
has resulted in people's well-being
being absent from policy making which
has resulted in
suffering and inequality and a
feeling of anxiousness over what's
coming you know people have
learned that they are just sort of being
carried along planktonically rather than
being
the um the objective of policy in some
way
and it's resulting in lots of incoherent
lashing out right it's resulting in the
lashing out at immigrants it's resulting
in the lashing out
at government it's resulting in um
lashing out
uh one race against another and
uh i basically think it's incoherence
that we are seeing rather than
strategies that are you know
locked in some kind of battle it's it's
it's a it's a loss of meaning and
and coherence more than anything else
do you have thoughts on neanderthal
predation and raping of early humans
if true what would be the genetic legacy
and could it support brett's idea of
genes seeking self-replication at the
expense of other
i don't think that's not your that's not
your idea no it's not my idea
um yeah of course it could leave a
genetic legacy yeah legacy it could also
die out
but yeah i guess i would say
i think there's an awful lot that we
could learn if we had better information
about what had taken place
between those two sister taxa um
but i don't think we do have good
information yet yeah
uh final question from this live stream
before switching to
the next one i'm from peru and in recent
years i've noticed that many american
tourists come here to drink and
experience
and experience ayahuasca why is this
happening please
um i think it's uh
it's a get wise quick scheme not the
drinking so much
no um i mean i think it's it's really
too different
so there's the recreational people
coming who are drinking and oh hey of
course i'm going to go do ayahuasca
yeah at some level it has become
relatively inexpensive to do the
traveling
people are very focused on what they can
report back to their social
groups of course you know
drinking is just sort of a constant mode
and
ayahuasca is something you can
definitely report back and people will
want to hear what you have to say
and um so it's not surprising
that a people who are in a position to
produce ayahuasca have discovered that
they can
uh earn by allowing gringos to
to partake and that
um b that gringos are interested in
doing it because it you know there's a
kind of
extreme ethos and ayahuasca is extreme
in this regard right there are lots of
things that you can find short of
ayahuasca
but people don't necessarily get real
excited to hear about your mushroom trip
they definitely want to hear about
ayahuasca and they aspire to do it
themselves because they want to be
telling a story somebody else wants to
listen to
and so anyway i think all of this is a
bit tragic because i do
think especially if one attempts to meet
ayahuasca on its own ground
right its own um spiritual
context and i say that guardedly right
but the point is those who have
have wielded ayahuasca for thousands of
years
have some insight into
what is to be derived and how to derive
it
and it is not necessarily clear that you
can just simply
create that scenario for gringos in
peru but um the attempt is necessary and
you know
basically you don't want you want the
remote version
you don't want you know what would be
the equivalent of
yeah i went to mexico but really what
you did is you know you went to
yeah um so
uh you know there are those who are
serious about
these things and there are those who are
just finding a market opportunity and
exploiting it and
it matters a great deal with
hallucinogens context matters
so much and in this case maybe even more
than normal
all right beginning with super chat
questions from this hour
check chloe's tweet on james baldwin uh
from his book the fire next time
there are some similarities to your
youtube video speak at the devil
also please have chloe on again she's
the best um i'm wondering if this is a
new so
chloe uh valderry is a huge fan
of james baldwin as we came to now
actually when we spent a few days with
her
when is when which is also when she was
on the podcast
she's fabulous and if this is this is a
new tweet it'll be easy to find
whenever i see a self-perpetuating
dysfunction i get suspicious
particularly when it happens
generationally and especially when in
pairs
in contrast to mind viruses might some
evils have two genders
um i think there might be something very
interesting here
but that it's slightly encoded and i'm
not sure what
i'm not sure how to crack the code quite
when it happens
generationally and especially in pairs
is this is about
um what's the term
uh codependency
yeah two dysfunctions that need each
other
um so i'd be curious what the examples
are here yeah i think the examples would
help us unpack what that means
yeah um but yes it is entirely possible
for something that is um
not viable on its own to be viable in
partnership with something else and it
is possible to pair two such things so
anyway
interesting idea i'd love to know
exactly what you're thinking about
the militant moderate asks um the
articles of unity youtube channel ought
to release a montage of people from both
parties
claiming that we'll spoil the election
for the other side may be collected
from twitter and facebook posts loved
the chat with governor ventura
um that would be interesting i must tell
you
i think you know the whole purpose of
the structure
of unity 2020 was to achieve
a kind of balance that would avoid
spoiling
and in many ways this has worked exactly
as i hoped in fact
it has exceeded my expectations quite a
bit one way in which i do not see
balance so far is that democrats
insist that this is going to spoil the
election for
trump even though the evidence suggests
that if anything
to the extent that there is a slight
bias it draws more from trump supporters
than biden supporters so it would tend
to spoil it the other direction to the
very tiny
extent that there's any tendency of that
nature at all well the question claims
that both
people from both sides are making this
claim right i don't see the ones
coming from the right saying that it's
going to spoil for biden
right so it's possible that that has
something to do with the way
what you're seeing yeah but it was
because this this
looks like this question makes it sound
like
that exists on both sides i would expect
it to but i would expect it to also
if it exists on both sides this is a
great idea and i would love to see it
but i don't want to
portray in any way or magnify the degree
to which
um the republicans seem less concerned
about this if they do
well more power to them but i mean
uh more power to those who are not
frightened by this particular boogeyman
which keeps us
locked in the monopoly you know maybe
the thing that i'm
one of the things that i'm really
excited about with regard to unity and i
don't remember the numbers and i'm sure
they change
regularly and i don't know who's who's
generating them
um but the idea that a substantial
fraction
of the people who are voicing support
for unity are people who say that they
would not otherwise be voting
and to me that makes it seem like
a critique of it on the basis that you
will spoil an election that has to be
between two parties is an inherently
criticism it is unpatriotic and
anti-democratic in the extreme how
dare you challenge anything that brings
disaffected voters
back into the process that is very much
the way the parties see things but no
rational decent person should see it
that way bringing back people back into
the process
is part of how we reinvigorate it and
make it work in the interests of the
public
so i absolutely agree with you that it's
it's like 25
yeah i thought i thought i'd seen even
in the 30s at one point
yeah let's see
is there an evolutionary explanation for
phobias to lizards spiders snakes etc
and if it is or used to be beneficial to
fear them why are some people deathly
afraid while others aren't too bothered
thanks for everything you do so this
question will have come in after we
answered that earlier question about
snakes and i think it it plays right
into it that
basically most places where there are
snakes
some of those snakes are going to be
poisonous and it's
uh easier and safer to have in across
the board phobia
i've been places where there were some
very very wrong beliefs
about um you know for instance one place
i
spent a field season in uh
southeastern i can't remember some place
in costa rica
um suggested that boas
are baby cortalets or baby pit vipers
and so if you kill bows whenever you see
them you will decrease the population of
pit vipers and of course this is no
truth whatsoever and the boas there
don't grow big enough to cause any harm
to you and you really should not be
killing them but people would hack off
it would hack up boas with machetes
whenever they
saw them and this is really really
unfortunate
but it did speak to this larger truth
that actually there
the pit vipers of which there were
several species could be deadly
and and they were dangerous and hacking
them up when you saw them although not
something that i ever did
um did probably leave more people around
um if they manage their
you know the spaces around their houses
like that
um i have this i have this silly thing
that i
i say that i think just in my anecdotal
experience
um the people seem people who you know
live who grew up like we did
you know without having to be forced to
regularly
worry about uh organisms like this
actually
uh getting into our homes and causing
causing harm
um tend to have a phobia of either the
things with very very few legs or a lot
a lot of legs
um that a lot of us don't particularly
like spiders but are
quite an emirate of snakes and vice
versa and i see no reason why this would
actually be true but i sort of enjoy
recognizing this in people when
uh when i see it yep i am of the camp
that fears things with odd numbers of
legs
on numbers of legs so after the cat has
bitten a leg off a spider then then you
become
a feared however they get there um yeah
i will say
i think the general answer here is one
of the
magical things about the way our minds
work and develop
is that we may have a prejudice that's
built in
like there may be an underlying
prejudice against snakes because
if you don't know something about a
snake um there's a danger that it will
be dangerous to you and there's
a limited value of uh
you're encountering the snake and not
worrying about it now of course if you
eat snakes that's different
so basically you want to be able to
reschedule these things based on
where you are a general fear of snakes
in a place where there's no dangerous
snakes maybe snakes are a safe food
source and a place where
some snakes are dangerous but most
aren't maybe you need to get really
focused on which snake you're dealing
with and think about where you're
putting your feet
so there's every reason to have the
software be flexible
and some basic prejudice against things
that are sometimes dangerous like
spiders for example
makes some sense it also makes sense for
you to be able to develop
a fear of something that comes
to be frightening to you through
information right like something you
wouldn't fear
that you realize is more dangerous than
you think like
you know you and i almost got caught in
a flash flood uh when we were in costa
rica during
an early field season so i've never
looked at rivers the same way
after that i you know i saw something
but you can imagine the software is
flexible for every reason you would want
it to be
and that means that you can get bad
stuff in the software and you can be
irrationally afraid of something that
isn't really a hazard or as a hazard so
rarely like you know airplane crashes is
hazard so rarely that
any to whatever degree you are dissuaded
from doing something because you're
afraid of being in a
airliner crash you're making an error
so you know flexibility is good but it
leaves open the possibility of bad
programming that's arbitrary and that's
not good yeah no absolutely and i guess
just one more thing here
um i don't think any of these examples
that are given in the question lizards
spiders and snakes of course as we said
earlier snakes
are a type of legless lizard um
have the capacity to spread disease to
us um
i don't think any spiders can
but i'll spider correct me if you think
i'm wrong but i think i can't think of
an example
um all spiders do have venom so all
spiders can envenomate but most of them
don't do so in any in any way that's
gonna cause anything but a small a
slight irritation and of course most
spiders are small enough they'd be
hard-pressed to get anything into you
with regard to lizards though you know
that subset of lizards that aren't
snakes
um there's only one or two venomous
lizards at all so the idea of being
scared of lizards
um in any way is actually is is the
surprising one to me here and i you know
i say that as just someone who's a huge
fan of lizards
but it makes me wonder you know get sure
they can they have a bite and you know
you've got to know how to handle them if
you want to handle them
um but i don't think
that other than the one or two species i
just can't remember if it's one or two
of
actually venomous lizards non-snake
lizards um
if they're not actually potentially
vectoring any diseases
i don't think they do so there's like
there's lizard malaria and there's human
malaria but i don't think like an
anopheles mosquito that fights one can
bite the other and
and transmit lizard malaria to humans
yeah they can they can
uh tear open your skin some of them and
cause an infection but they don't
they're not vectoring disease
i don't i don't think so so the lizard
one is actually the surprising one to me
on that list unless people are
you know correctly intuiting the
phylogenetic connection which i
you know i doubt which is that um snakes
are lizards and therefore just you know
be wary of all the squamates
yep yep have you seen eric's latest
tweets
apparently he is in discussions with
jack dorsey about the unity twitter ban
he says it has reached the highest
levels of twitter corp yeah i saw one of
them
and it's hopeful yeah i can't say i've
seen them all but uh i was
up to date at some point before our
stream
i was quite surprised to hear some of
the things that jack seems to think
uh unity has engaged in as i said
on our main live stream it's a big
organization and so we're doing our best
to figure out whether there's something
that we should know that we don't know
but i believe twitter has misunderstood
what took place and that it has
treated unity very badly and i i must
say that at some level
i do suspect that there's something
political underlying that even if
we're being told otherwise
so this regarding the our our search for
the name of a category of book
that tends to be used as a sort of a
weapon to shut down conversation
i suggest you call the category of book
oscar wilde's defense
if you don't know why a book was written
it must have been written for a good
reason
so i think that last thing is said uh
with some with some irony
and this of course is reference to
chesterton's fence which we've mentioned
several times
um it's of course too too wordy and it
gives too much credibility gives gives
too much to osterweil or whoever name is
pronounced who wrote this
insane um book defending looting but i
like
i like the thinking and i'd like for us
to find the category name
yeah so i'm trying to parse exactly
what's being argued here this is
somebody who clearly agrees with us that
this book is preposterous
and is trying to name the category that
we were looking for a name for
yeah and so this
obviously functions the logic is the
inverse of
chesterton's fence because the reason
that a book is written
is at least partially going to be
because you can get paid to write it
you know if it's a book that somebody
thinks they can sell and at this moment
a book that defends looting
will sell because they're an awful lot
of people who are looking for somebody
to tell them
why this is okay now i think uh i don't
have it here i think it actually came
out
in may so um so
i think i think this was not written in
the last couple of months
um but it it speaks to a moment
uh that is years long although these
last few months are of course fever
pitch with regard to the moment
all right i may be wrong about that but
i think i saw that as surprising if true
yeah
um religion is literally false
metaphorically true
religious metaphorical truth becomes
outdated so becomes maladaptive
would it be a mind virus at this point
given that memes replicate and persist
um no the category you're looking for
is vestigial and vestigial is a very
overused claim with respect
to morphological stuff however
in this case the question is if
religion is now maladaptive and i
wouldn't argue that i would argue that
major components of it may be and maybe
it is net maladaptive
but you know there's going to be
elements of it that are closer to
timeless that are more likely to still
be paying
their freight they're going to be other
elements which are counterproductive
but that to the extent it is maladaptive
a population that doesn't believe those
things will have an advantage and it
will be
driven out through uh evolutionary
competition
so i'm not saying that is or isn't true
but i'm saying that would be
true in the case that it was not
maladaptive and so
that period of time in which it is
ebbing which i believe we are seeing
that period of time
religiosity has been decreasing and we
may be seeing people apply their
religious impulse to things
that are not religions but that ebbing
period would be the period of
elimination of those beliefs by an
evolutionary force
over time but what remained would be
vestigial if it was not paying its way
okay uh apparently the articles
have just been unsuspended wow
wild apparently so you should the
isn't following it's not replenished but
it will take time and be fully
understand
interesting so say it so apparently we
are being told by
not a small bird i mean if he was a bird
at all he'd be a very large bird
um that the articles of unity account
has just been
unsuspended so that's good news i wonder
what happened and will we ever know i
hope i hope we find out
that would be great yep so just to get
back to
my thinking that the book had been
published back in may what i had
remembered was actually that it
she claims it just came out on tuesday
of last week but she finished it in
april
which is you know consistent with a
standard publication schedule
and boy she really got lucky or she
really helped build riots fast
something um okay next question nope
wrong
uh there we go next next question
next comment i am not a democrat i'm not
a republican
i am not a robot i am seeking unity
hell yeah but you didn't wait not a
democrat not a republican not a robot
but you are seeking you you did not
established that you are not a russian
that is something else we have been
accused of but weren't the so the
russians weren't just russian bots it
was
actual russians bots russian bots just
you know for the win
russian bots for the win yes and i can
prove that i'm not a russian by virtue
of how terrible
my impression of a russian accent is
it's so bad i couldn't possibly be
russian that's
basically maybe you're just a bad
russian
um i i would think even a bad russian
i mean a bad russian if i'm to believe
the movies and cartoons that i've seen a
bad russian would have a particularly
thick
accent it would be readily detectable
empty bottles of vodka littered at your
feet
probably yes exactly and the the
sinister
nature of their being would just it
would emanate
forth you would probably smell it oh
it's a cartoon you don't smell much but
um but you could see the little waves
yeah a little expensive
yeah sinister thought okay
one hour okay well we're gonna do a few
more of these i am currently
reupholstering an old wing back chair
any tips
yes absolutely this is actually one one
skill that neither of us have any
experience in and you know there's a lot
of things you could ask us about oh
you're about to no
you don't know that i think i do if i
had a nickel for every wingback chair
i had reupholstered i
think i was gonna say i bet you can't
like describe a wing
back chair no in fact all i'm seeing is
wingtip shoes which i'm sure
well do you want to know how to
reupholster your wingtips yep brett is
the guy for you
absolutely that i have done yeah we have
no idea
no i'm sure there's youtube videos for
that
um probably
google uh new york city crime statistics
by race
dot nypd graphs
show oh show okay nypd graphs
show 90 to 98 all crime by black and
brown people
does more crime create worse cops does
less crime allow cops to be more calm
isn't this the root of the problem
first of all i wonder about those
statistics yeah that seems
that seems suspiciously way too high
but does more crime create worse cops
it certainly creates more stressed cops
um and
does less crime allow cops to be more
calm for sure
so more crime if you fix the level of
funding
then more crime will create worse cops
because
police brutality is basically a
substitute for proper funding
right so what do you mean if you fix if
if we imagine
if thought experiment wise if we fix the
amount of funding so you're not talking
about correcting you're talking about
fixing in place
right which which meaning of fix are you
using that's that's a crazy thing you
just said given the normal meaning of
the word fix
there are in fact three meanings of the
word oh this is going to be good one of
them is spelled
fix in place there is to fix as in
repair
and then there is fixing your animals oh
back to being a bad russian oh
oh no no i thought you were talking
about fixing like an election sometimes
you fix your cat or your dog as in
that'll fix them it's terrible
okay let's resume let's see we don't
answer any questions you don't mean if
you
correct uh police funding all hell is
gonna break loose which is
which is what it sounded like you said
if in our thought experiment if we
hold resources constant yep right
let's say we hold resources constant at
about the level that you
that policing matches the criminality so
you're getting a good return on
investment
and then we drive up the criminality
yeah but you don't have any more
policing
then the point is police in order to
keep crime down will end up behaving in
a more aggressive fashion so that people
will think
twice about behaving criminally because
they don't want to encounter the police
right so the and because they're
encountering they're having to encounter
they're having to
engage in more situations that are
dangerous
and uh they are more likely to be a hair
trigger as a result
so anyway i think that the upshot of
this if we put aside those suspicious
statistics
the upshot is if you
decrease funding of police you will
increase police brutality that is to say
bad policing
and you will increase crime right those
two things are predictable outcomes
of a decrease in police funding now it
could be that you have wildly overfunded
police and you don't see that effect
until you get
way lower but that's not where we are
because for one thing as you
have pointed out a number of times
police are being
used to do jobs that really aren't
inherently about policing like to deal
with the mentally ill
so the fact is police are
overburdened they may be improperly
trained they may be
improperly armed but they are
overburdened and reducing funding
without doing anything
else is going to result in more crime
and more brutality
yes do you believe
that democrats downplaying riots was or
is
with the belief that it would hurt trump
um i believe that the rioters
invoked trump so that people
on the nominal left would not
be able to say anything negative
and that basically this has become a get
out of morality free
card is if you simply put trump on the
other side of whatever you're doing
then most democrats can't figure out how
to say you still have to cut it out
yeah so sort of leaving the dems of the
capital d with no choice but to
go along with that interpretation right
and the fact is i think they of course
did have a choice but
they had a choice but basically people
are
people are on autopilot and they're not
understanding that that autopilot may
work for normal stuff but it is allowing
them to be routinely gamed now where
people can figure out how to tie you in
knots just simply by
portraying them as opposed to something
you don't like and it's you know
can you figure out how to challenge the
patriot act um
first thing you have to do is realize
it's not about patriotism
let's see multiple meow i think that was
in while we had two cats getting cream
on twitter i talked to mega people
what happens to them is they get mass
reported by organized groups
do you know why unity 2020 was suspended
also heather please read my name
laughter is important i'll fight you
naked
um okay we do know
that unity 2020 was reported by people
there are
quite a number of people who are um
very persistent in attacking unity 2020
on
many preposterous bases some of these
people
are angry at me i think for
challenging the ascendancy of
the woke ideology some of them
are um i think
troubled by uh the possibility that
unity will nominate somebody other than
andrew yang or that andrew yang has
having signed up with the democrats is
um
being taken as a sacred leader i don't
know quite what it is but yes
there are people who are irrationally
angry at unity there are people who
suspect it of being something other than
it is
either something to bolster our channel
here when in fact it
costs our channel that's quite a bit
since we don't monetize
any of the things that we have put out
in the context of unity
anyway we could go into why it's costly
but no this is you you
like it or hate it it's motivated by
exactly what we said it has been
motivated by which is a sense that the
nation is in danger
and that we need a solution and that
this is um
an emergency plan so anyway yes we do
know that it was reported
and the fact is that a system
in which your enemies can report
whatever you're doing
and that gives twitter or whatever
platform license to do whatever it wants
because it's to say oh well you were
reported for spamming or whatever it was
that is a system in which the platform
is given
complete discretion to do what it wants
and
you know it can hide behind the idea of
reports by people who were
motivated by confusion or uh
malevolence or whatever yeah
four more have you read ron owens's
myth of american meritocracy no is the
answer to that part of the question
i don't i doubt you have either nope it
argues that jewish whites are 450
overrepresented as ivy league students
compared to their percentage of high
ability students in the general
population
do you have thoughts well that
i don't think it argues it sounds like
it claims yeah
it puts forth a number that is or is not
true
yeah um and you know i so the question
is like if if that is true
yeah um then what do we make of it
but we have to you know if that is true
but you know plenty of people have
have said you know what um east asians
and jewish people are over-represented
compared to other demographics at um
in for instance the ivy league and i
mean i think
your argument here is going to be just
the same as when you're talking about
any of these
race or ethnicity and intelligence or
capability or success
uh questions it's that it doesn't have
to live in the hardware layer and in
fact you don't expect it to yeah i think
it lives at the seder table and i think
it
did you know yeah the fact is uh
i i know more ashkenazi jews than i do
sephardic jews but i will say ashkenazi
tables it is very frequent for people to
have good-natured
but pointed arguments with each other
about stuff that
matters and the fact is i think it
creates a culture of holding each
other's feet to the fire it creates a
culture of
you know getting your ducks in a row
before you make an argument and figuring
out which arguments are secure and which
ones are going to give
way underneath you and that that has
impact and
frankly i think it's valuable i think it
has a lot to do
with having lived this diaspora which is
a very vulnerable
position to live in and that
you know there's clearly something going
on with
success in certain realms by ashkenazi
jews and
i think it's worth learning from yeah
and you know the seder table i mean i
think actually
the seder table as a model that can be
moved into
other realms of life would be a very
powerful thing to explore and as you
were talking i thought you know
of course i didn't grow up with a cedar
table in my own house but i got to
i got to to visit many um
among family friends and and friends um
and i think
that you and i both you know together
sort of co-created
a kind of seder table phenomenon in our
classroom so that is actually what we
did
and it's the opposite of the now
common use of the term safe space we
created spaces
where we actually had respect and trust
for one another
our students and us and they knew that
when we disagreed with them or
criticized them that we were not making
um the personal accusation about them or
claiming that they were not worthy but
perhaps their
ideas weren't uh and we were willing to
get into it with them and this this
created an
actual it's like a a seder space
it's you know it's a it's it is it is an
actual safe space
that creates anti-fragility rather than
um rather than weaklings it is a
socially
safe space created amongst people who
are honorable enough
to handle it and it it creates the right
incentive you know because if we
you know if we challenge the student's
argument and
you know that's weak because if that
were true it would predict these things
which we don't see
and then the student thinks about it and
they say actually i think it's true
because x y or z and then you say yep
you got it right
that's that's compelling then the point
is it
reinforces this sort of careful thinking
and extrapolation
behavior that is the stuff of uh nuanced
thought
yeah three more
hi brett your perspective has been very
insightful and influential on my
thinking i'm curious
if you think that unity 2020 could lead
the way to game b
good question um i have been talking to
people in
many different realms about the idea
that these
things are all manifestations of the
same phenomenon
in different realms so i don't see it as
just unity and game b
i see unity as the i mean
it's a political but in a political
realm it is a manifestation of the same
kind of thinking
that game b is at a complex systems and
society level which is the same thing
as idw is in discussion space
as open source movement is in
the technological space as um
uh blockchain and crypto is potentially
to the financial space
all of these things are attempts to
solve a systems level problem with a
higher quality answer
that is stable and competitively viable
and anyway my hope
is that all of these different entities
are going to recognize
the shared objective at a system
that works with minimal architecture and
that they will join forces because
that's a much more powerful
response to the problems that we find
ourselves with
than each of us trying to solve our
problem individually and
thinking that those other projects have
nothing to do with it yep
i realized i skipped one and it's a
comment so i'll go back to it and then
we'll do
the last two wait until the pro rioting
lady realizes that many words in english
that refer to government institutions
come from the norman
oppression of the english if you're
interested there's a very good language
focus on this
i admit i don't know what words we're
talking about
can either of you offer your insights on
styles of instruction between
institutions methods shared in academic
learning or medical training versus
corporate or military style training
any observations would be appreciated
god there's just there's so much to say
about education and
you know i don't we know less about for
instance exactly what happens within
say military um or even
even at medical schools um one important
distinction
being that when there is an understood
goal
you know in something that can be called
a trade school or professional school
where you're there to
become a doctor or become a coder or
whatever
there is less room in the curriculum for
exploration and
for just kind of sitting around and
exchanging ideas and you don't know what
the goal is and that's what
um liberal arts is supposed to do it's
supposed to provide
room for exploration such that uh you
can
not only be your best self so so that
you can go out into the world and make a
difference and
and and make a living but also become
your best self
uh so those that's one distinction that
i would make that is an important one
um i would argue that the hidden
secret to improving education in
everything is understanding the
motivational structures
underneath and that what we saw with
people educated in the standard way who
then
came to us is that they very often had
perverse incentives built into
their mode in other words if you were a
very good student
and being a good student got a lot of
accolades from the people at the front
of the room
maybe you got very focused on what the
people at the front of the room
thought rather than what was actually
true which meant that you couldn't
innovate beyond what the person at the
front of the room knew
because they would think it was wrong
and you would have to have the courage
of your convictions
which you hadn't learned the the the
taste for
so in all of these things you want
the person to want to engage in the
exercise that makes them
smarter or wiser and you want success to
line up exactly with the thing
that they should accomplish when they
get out of the exercise and into the
the real thing and so you know
ultimately if we survive what will
education look like
it's going to look like games puzzles
exercises role playing all sorts of fun
stuff sitting around campfires together
sitting around campfires yes
in fact exploring remote places um
hopefully eventually if we do our job
right
um you stop knowing when you're working
and when you're not and when you're
learning and when you're not that these
things
bleed into each other so seamlessly that
you basically know that there's stuff
that you feel rewarded for
doing and either it's enhancing your
tool kit or it's wielding your tool kit
or it's doing both but that the process
of being human becomes
uh intuitive and highly productive
last one is a comet that's a good one to
end on today is wonderful
i watched the campfire show i have some
ice cold beer and now i have two hours
of two happy cats and two beautiful
intelligent podcast hosts
i really love the insights you both give
and thanks for all that you do
thank you man what a great note to end
on yeah that just feels so good and i
bet the cats feel good about it too oh
no doubt they're off
looking for steak i expect presumably
yes
yeah all right well thank you for that
yeah thank you thank you so much
we will not be back on tuesday we will
be back in
a week with another live stream there
will be at least one dark horse podcast
well there will be one dark horse
podcast being released
between now and then and i think at
least one campfire as well maybe more
than that from
from unity yeah stay tuned um assuming
our unity account really is back
up if you're not signed up for it please
sign up on twitter
um give us your email address in case
somebody else comes after us and
cancels our account do that at
articlesofunity.org
um sign up for you have a patreon thing
upcoming oh yes we have we have the
private q a
for uh uh for dark horse members
tomorrow at 11 a.m so if you sign up on
my patreon
um at the 5 or more level before
tomorrow at 11 you'll be able to go and
see the link for that
and we'll do a two-hour q a the
questions we've already received
um in the beginning of the month you
will be doing your big ticket patreon
conversations um i cannot believe this
month is over
and and so it goes yep all right and so
it goes
good well anyway it's been great folks
and we'll see you next time
um get outside yes get outside while the
sun still shines alright be well
you